hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're in
round number three of the 2019 u.s.
Chess Championship held in st. Louis
gonna be happening for the next few
weeks our competitors today White's
gonna be played by nakamura many of you
familiar he plays in all the big
tournaments the third highest rated
american partly just cuz we have some
really talented American chess players
with Fabiano Caruana and also wesley
social sitting a top above nakamura his
competitor playing the black pieces is
sam seven we watched this 18 year old
play yesterday and get the victory he
currently sits atop the standings only
two days in but he's no stranger to
meeting some top competition in 2015 so
four years ago when he was just a young
lad he beat wesley so so this definitely
his for the taking if he wants it but he
does have a challenge in front of him
he's playing the black pieces against
one of the strongest american so we'll
go and get started with Nakamura pon to
C for the English opening pawn to e5
think of it as the reverse Sicilian if
you're not familiar with English opening
night c3 Knight f6 both sides decide to
go into the four nights of variation and
then pawn to e4 so you can be pretty
aggressive pawn to e4 if you wanted to
be a little slower you could always play
pawn to e3 stopping the bishop coming
down here to b4 Nakamura decides to go
and play pawn a four now Bishop down
before pinning down the Knights decided
to go and play pawn to d3 not too
worried about the bishop taking right
here now pawn to d6 just solidifying the
pawn chain pawn to a3 and then the
bishop comes back here to c5 if after
pawn to d3 let's say the bishop takes
here on c3 White's gonna have a pretty
solid punch and you have all these pawns
in the center of the board
maybe castle on the King side Bishop e2
d6 this isn't terrible for white so
Nakamura didn't really mind if this
happened in the game or not but after
the bishop comes back here we see pawn
up to
before forcing the [ __ ] to come back
Bishop here to be 6 and then Knights a
for attacking the bishop here on be 6
black continues bringing his light
square Bishop to the game with Bishop to
g4 thought he may try to bring his
Bishop down to d4 really just keep this
night on a4 exactly where it is you
don't want to give him an easy Square to
come to you want to keep your opponent's
pieces in bad positions and definitely
the Knights here on the a or the H file
are not good positions and now if
Nakamura wants to exchange I think this
is a great outpost for this knight in
the center of the board yes White has
the bishop pair but he can have the
bishop pair later on if he wants to if
he leads his Bishop here on b6 he's just
going to lose his own Bishop but this
does start to clog up the center of the
board so the bishops don't mean as much
as far as the bishop hair but in the
game we see the bishop coming back here
after Knight to a4 then Bishop down to
g4 pinning down the Knights Bishop to e2
both stopping the threat of the pin as
well as getting ready to castle on the
Kings side not coming back to d7 and
then the knight takes on b6 so yes the
knight came back here it is not there to
protect it would be a mistake to go
ahead and take with the Knights right
here because then then I could take here
on e5 and then after the knight takes we
could see the bishop take and I take and
then the Queen recaptures you can see
why it's gonna be up in material so not
exactly what Sam would be going for so
instead in the game after the knight
takes we are gonna see the pawn
recapture here on b6 so does have double
pawns on the B file and white still has
that bishop pair so that's what I say if
you know if he's gonna have it anyway I
felt like getting a nice little outpost
here on d4 makes a lot of sense now
nakamora plays Bishop to b2 just trying
to control the dark square diagonals
castle on the King side pawn eights
three forcing in the light square bishop
to move decided to go ahead and take
here in exchange now that I come
down to addy for the great little
outpost Nakamura says yeah I'm not gonna
hold on to my bishop hair it's starting
to get closed up in the center so
doesn't even know that the bishop pair
is gonna matter as much so castle on the
Kings side we do see the exchange here
on f3 and then the Queen comes down to
g5 so it's equal in material both from a
material standpoint but then also you
could see black does have double pawns
here so not as great but he has the
better minor piece in my opinion then I
can just move all over the board
especially in a closed position both
sides have pretty safe Kings there is
one semi open file that this rook here
can attack knows to me open files for
the white rook so no real clear attack
for either side here this backward pawn
eventually someone could attack but no
clear attack for either side so as we
continue rook to e1 just centralizing
Knight coming back to b8 pretty much as
yeah I'm gonna come back here to start
pushing forward with c6 anytime you see
your opponent retreat material back
especially the minor pieces that usually
means it's a good time to strike if you
have a good attack and that's exactly
what Nakamura does he senses a little
bit of weakness and he starts pushing
forward Pondy for now Knight to c6 but
we can start to see some exchange from
Nakamura so after the pawn takes then we
see rook here to d1 before white did not
have an open file to attack with the
rooks now he absolutely has that so it
controls the stern on the board rook to
d8 and then rook up here to d5 says yeah
if you want to exchange I'm now gonna
control this with my pawns after the
rook takes decided to go and take with
his C Pawnee could also take here this
does have a pretty solid pawn structure
but really wanted to hold on to two
central pawns so decided to go ahead and
take with his C pawn foreseen the
Knights move Knight comes down here to
d4 this is fine with Nakamura he
exchanges and now this pond completely
isolated the S it is a passed pawn but
it's gonna be so difficult to hold on to
the only piece that he can really
control it with is the queen here
decides to go ahead and try with his
pawns after Queen to d3 place pawn c5
but yeah it's just it's just too little
to really try to hold on to it
Nakamura does play on poisson sim for
those not familiar with on pissant you
can't actually take like this you have
one move and one move only after your
opponent moves two squares here so it
has capture after the pawn recaptures
the nakamura takes in the pond getting
into the endgame Nakamura against an
opponent that is definitely inferior to
his playing skill getting into that with
a pawn advantage huge huge benefits for
Nakamura pawn to c5 would you see the
Queen to come up here to d6 attacking
both the pawns here and also just
preparing for an attack on to the King
you have the the constant threat of the
back rank maid if you're not familiar
exactly what that means if the rook were
to come down and take on a3 this is
going to be checkmate Queen to b8
nowhere for the King to move the rook is
completely out of the picture the only
way to stop it Queen to d8 but then it's
going to be checkmate right away so yes
this Queen does come up there's a lot of
different things that it's doing so yes
adding more and more pressure but it
also just stops this rook here on a8
from doing anything Sam plays pawn
taking on b4 pawn recaptures Queen over
here to a b5 attacking the pawn but then
rook over here to see one doesn't have
to worry too much because the Queen here
on d6 is still defending this pawn here
on b4 so pawn to h6 if you look at and
say you know how does black really get
out of this he wants to get his rook in
bottom to the game he wants to maybe
double attack here on this pawn before
but as soon as he moves his rook he
knows it's going to be lights out so he
needs to make sure that if his opponent
or yeah puts him in check he can move
his King so that's what he does
Ponce h6 but this really takes a move
off he no longer is developing or
figuring out the best way to
put these major pieces into play
Nakamura king could just continue with
his plan putting his pieces together for
the best attack Queen to see six Queen
comes back eight-six pushing forward
pawn to b5 stopping both the pawn from
pushing as well as continuing to attack
the Queen Queen out here to a5 rook to
d1 just getting ready to push if it
needs to Brooke to b8 King up here to h2
Queen down to 82 that's just not what
the game is about yes you're attacking
the pawn here on f2 but really needs to
just figure out how to defend correctly
Queen to c7 you know threatening
obviously taking the rook here on b8
really has to bring his queen back here
sort of a wasted move here attacking on
a 2 now rook to d7 you've heard me in
many videos getting your rook to your
opponent's 7th rank if you're white or
if you're black bringing it down here to
the second ranks exactly where you want
to be if you have a queen supporting you
as well things are pretty deadly you can
see right away that they are attacking
this f8 or f7 Square and from there it's
pretty much all going to be over so rook
to f8 but now Sam's just in complete
defense mode
his rook is no longer gonna be involved
in any sort of attack here we see the
Queen take on b6 the Queen takes on e4
and then my favorite move of the game so
far and that is Queen to d6 it seems
subtle it's just centralizing but it
does so much when it opens up the door
for the pond to start pushing as soon as
it comes to b6 it's protected by the
Queen it comes here to b7 it's protected
by the rook and if it comes here to b8
its protected by the Queen this Queen
here also is attacking and defending
this entire diagonal right here so if
the rook were to ever come here to b8
can't do that it's being under attack
and really what Sam wants to do is find
a way to check his opponents but it
can't do that really
he just is working with this dark square
diagonal this Queen here on d6 is
locking that up so this
simple little move here just
centralizing is doing so much for
Nakamura in the end game Queen comes
back here to e6 Nakamura says yeah
that's fine we'll go ahead and exchange
I'm up upon the material when you get
down to the the even game if you're up
it's okay to exchange because your
advantage just becomes that more
pronounced in the game so pawn to b6 has
the passed pawn
number one thing to do with a passed
pawn is continue to push it King to h7
pawn appear to be seven pretty much have
to just think about how I'm going to
defend this King to g6 rook over here to
c7 rook to b8 just trying to stop that
does not want Nakamura to play rook to
c8 that is the threat that he is
stopping there King to g3 announced this
tough position because black really
wants to keep white from getting his
King over to the Queen side of the board
he's gonna have to do that with
something like King to f5 but as soon as
he moves King TFI he's going to lose
this pawn here on g7 but if he doesn't
if he plays King to f6 well then he has
to worry about his opponent playing him
to f4 and then maybe he can attack it
with his pawns but then the king is just
gonna start going over to the Queen side
of the board this is not going to be a
winning strategy for Sam not that
there's too much he can do in this spot
but he decides to go and play King to f5
give up the pawn here on a g7 rook to d8
pawn here to f3 and then we see a series
of moves but at the end you could see
that there's just no way to stop
Nakamura in the game and so after a
while Nakamura then plays rook to c6 and
in this spot
Sam resigns so Nakamura you know had two
draws coming into this but still played
extremely strong had some tough
competitors in the first two rounds goes
up against the man at the top after two
rounds I recognized that but takes a
victory from him so that puts him in a
good spot in the tournament Sam on the
other hand had a great tournament
you know first round heats
I had Fabiano and then the second round
he did get a victory and thought he
played extremely well in this game just
you know a few minor calculations on his
ins ended up being down upon and just
can't do that getting into the end game
against Nakamura guy just does not make
mistakes so hopefully you guys enjoyed
round number three and enjoying the
tournament as well we will be back again
tomorrow for round number four thanks
for watching